quatrième anniversaire aujourd'hui en
catalogne du référendum
d'autodétermination une date
particulière pour les indépendantistes
catalans plus de précisions à barcelone
avec clémentine euros quatre ans que les
catalans ont voté pour l'indépendance de
la région durant un référendum non
autorisées un scrutin qui même plusieurs
années après et toujours lourd de
conséquences après le référendum en 2017
les dirigeants indépendantistes
responsable de ce dernier avait été
condamné et emprisonné et même s'ils
avaient été graciés en juin dernier il
ne s'agit pas d'une amnistie totale s'il
récidive ils iront en prison et il reste
à aujourd'hui inéligible il ya aussi les
maires qui sont responsable également de
l'organisation du référendum dans les
autres villes de catalogne qui sont
toujours en attente de jugement et puis
surtout il y à la sphère putsch emon
l'ancien président catalan qui avait
déclaré l'indépendance a aujourd'hui en
espagne il est toujours en exil il est
recherché par la police espagnole et
même si la possibilité d'extrader push
damon vers l'espagne reste compliquée et
bien c'est toujours l'objectif des
tribunaux espagnols alors les
manifestations et événements prévus ce
week-end de dureront trois jours durant
lesquels les indépendantistes
revendiqueront notamment
l'autodétermination de la catalogne mais
aussi surtout l'aministie total de cas
l'ex posh damon et des autres dirigeants
indépendantistes qui avaient été
condamnées en 2017 reste à savoir si ces
appels seront entendus par madrid ou
bien si le gouvernement espagnol
demeurera inflexible sur ces questions